[Music]
Atika capacitor people fell on to access
transport a she-wolf aha traditionally
Karnas educator on typical Divya zapping
mm very conscious wah to determine the
man Jerry masala and Patrick with a pan
transfer fancy nama saya trio knocks but
a ponderous value CA o TT Pacific
terrain transform makea da Cunha give
apples one if you got a Makita
prioritized Waianae together at random
ultimately bubble
congeniality funky pastor ma understand
territory food in mouth prospect value
to chew better if you wanna run young
couple to a new sushi and silky Tom who
police a sea [ __ ] command Amalia is
the lanyard applause applause officer
gotama finish I see identification of
manga number that the truth - thump a
plan computer engineers capacity a fan
kita motor hundred witnessing yang South
to single sip and you know the party
took in satellite even willjack though
was your dad
blew it defied approach Allah Rakha it's
a visa program a career depression you
know given appropriate strategies and
enter America come on a uterus Polan
lacki katana brann bergen again impacts
our image the Canadian workers awakening
[Music]
today's journey takes us to the Dutch
town of guitar key thorn is just like
any normal town with one exception roads
they don't have them the immense of the
sine alpha is open boat someone's gonna
die violently the feature of the
platform the stem Acoma and others most
local severe Eggman's present a local
Burgermeister from Quito now I design
fear and the home that a modest over
here and I love homeless versions and
boats lots of boats now who adduction no
fear zone for faithfulness s all the
board to develop a daughter that's young
one of the town's residents he's known
for punters a flat-bottomed boat that
originated in Quito
a fellow Stanek he daughter modern
moment L hatchet over there over the
elevator and where there are boats there
are bridges 167 to be exact and just
like any town people leave their
groceries their furniture their beer you
name it
but in guitar they must pass through an
time he's the town's bridge guard it
also girls masters to may stop up and
lift that little daughter still when
they look at that often three on the
boat why we do so opening for one of
those boats is a fire boat this is Bart
and Eric I need to haul that black
Valley there's a middle renewed can call
those view hidden AutoKey toward ya feel
plan Phil warning in observance for
bruising from drunk now there are model
for the rather from the evil drinking
and boat and the singing design of
and this is young he's in charge of
maintaining the natural lands around II
thought I was alone clear lower than the
Mesa violin and sang corner better a
boat but egg bad and yeah the cooing of
the boat that's even a lot me to fill me
but a sober to succeed or no ha
ferocious animal so there you have it
the residents of Quito improved that a
life without asphalt traffic and trips
to the DMV can be pretty damn great
roads who needs him baggy torn first of
all were girly girls we like to be cute
but we still get dirty every time we
come out our shoes our outfits are
always matching eye makeup is done is it
hard to write in heels
no because if you walk in them you can
probably ride in them
we're not the typical biker chicken when
the curves come on the set is complete
chaos
my name is true and I'm one of the
founders of caramel curves motorcycle
club here in New Orleans my name is Coco
and I'm one of the founders and the
president of caramel kurz motorcycle
club we are a motorcycle club like no
others we come our club ready every time
we hit the streets when we first started
off I just rolled by myself and then
Coco she just rolled by herself and kind
of got together and was like let's start
something together cuz the guys always
have their bike clubs but what's more
sexy than riding on a bunch of girls
nothing nothing at all
the name caramel kurz was made up by
luck we came up with caramel cuz of the
complexion of our skin and then we came
up with curse but soul reason but when
we take curves on a motorbike better
than a mane and we some curvy girl
we are mothers we are daughters we are
everything that every other average
woman is in a world I'm really really
passionate about female empowerment
women knowing that they can do whatever
they want to do riding bikes used to be
a guy thing we're still being
discriminated against across the board
being a caramel curve we have demanded
our respect I just encourage any woman
that wants to ride a bike that thinks
that she can't do it girl you can do
that [ __ ] you know
go ahead the coolest thing about being a
caramel curved bike a chick is the
response and a love that we get from
from kids up to women when the little
kids look up to us it's that thing that
makes her feel like you know what if she
can do it I can do it you that's what
makes you feel like yeah you know what
let's keep your we doing being a caramel
card I truly feel like is my legacy I'm
gonna ride across country I'm gonna go
live and I'm gonna do it in heels
[Music]
just let you know that the flight time
is going to be roughly a minute and 20
seconds today this is West ray Island
Airport and this is Papa Western Island
Airport there only 1.7 miles away from
each other and are connected by the
world's shortest commercial flight
the average flying time is about 80
seconds
these two islands are a part of the
Orkney Islands in northern Scotland this
archipelago is defined by jagged
coastlines and it's obvious lack of
trees
there are 70 islands in total only 20 of
them are inhabited on some islands like
Papa Westray the population is less than
100 to get around up here
most people slide on this plane the
inter-island logan air route
Collin here he's the head pilot :
McAllister I'm the senior pilot the
aircraft we fly in automated cabbies the
passengers are the highest that we reach
a build with 350 feet altitude so it's
quite long it flies around about 150
miles an hour and it has the
aerodynamics of a brick but it's super
for what we do in the islands so why
does this flight exist because there are
so few people in the Orkney Islands
building bridges doesn't make financial
sense they just wouldn't get enough use
so if you live up here there are only
two ways to get around one you can take
this ferry which is super super slow or
two you can fly my name is Kate and I
live one don't me mainland but I fly out
to several of the islands teaching music
on a weekly basis once every three weeks
and flying is your display to get to
work the flight is used almost like a
bus service it acts like a bus route but
it's not it takes a team from the two
air traffic controllers okay that's too
clear to lend to the four firefighters
they all work together to help keep the
flight safe over the years I've flown
somewhere between four or five thousand
times between Westry and Paco Westry
it's community spirit that drives the
people who work at the airfields the
world's shortest flight has been around
for a long time the here have been
flying it for 50 years in Orkney at this
point it's a well-oiled machine
our only complaint no drink service
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Laughlin can go literal Indian really
has this for us so tactically all of
India it was the first possible k-means
[Music]
lifeline Express has been around for
about 25 years there has been over a
million patient encounters since of
crafted and over a hundred thousand
surgeries I am dr. lugar Suhani I am a
neurologist the mission has been to take
medical services to the people wherever
deprivation disability and poverty
coexist
rural India doesn't really have much of
healthcare facilities lifeline Express
has operation theatres and area for
consultations and minor procedures and
coaches fault
office space and so on the lifeline
Express focuses on cataract surgeries
issues like cleft lip and cleft palate
epilepsy breast and oral cancer and
family planning before the project
happens there is publicity in the
markets in the town then there are
posters put up there are patients that
are coming around from the surrounding
areas there are some days when I have
seen close to 100 patients already at
every project we get at least about 25
to 30 voluntary doctors and then there
are about 25 to 30 doctors who come in
from the location itself our patients
are grateful for what
and I see it as a way to give back
I think empathy letting them know that
whatever is possible is being done and
more importantly hearing them out it all
is part of the healing process
[Music]